okay so let's start with a very bizarre
press conference that Donald Trump gave
where he did all sorts of things that
make very little sense and what I want
to point out about this press conference
in particular is that Donald Trump seems
barely conscious in this press
conference so the bone white eyes in the
middle of an orange face his eyes
half-closed he sounds like he's on
ambien or Downers barely awake and
reminder this is a clip of a press
conference about covin 19 and the death
of a patient and Trump is rambling
incoherently about Isis slurring
sniffing short of breath take a look and
listen at this first clip from this
bizarre press conference again it's been
it's been a long journey in Afghanistan
in particular it's been a very long
journey it's been a it's been a hard
journey for everybody we're very largely
a law-enforcement group and that's not
what our soldiers are all about their
fighters are the greatest fighters in
the world as you know we've destroyed in
Syria and Iraq 100% of the Isis
Caliphate 100% we have thousands of
prisoners we've killed Isis fighters by
the thousands the labored breathing
combined with his barely awake voice and
rambling about Isis it's all very weird
then here's Trump strangely talking
about the sacrifices that have been made
in Afghanistan and he comes apart
talking about the expenditure of
treasure the expenditure of treasury in
the fight again what on earth is this
guy talking about seemingly soon
ambulant I guess most of all I want to
thank all of the people in the United
States for having spent so much in terms
of blood in terms of treasure
and Treasury the money that has been
spent the lives that have been lost and
we just signed an agreement that puts us
in a position to get it done bring us
down to in the vicinity of 8,000 troops
the United Nations was informed of
everything and NATO has been great
secretary Stoltenberg has been fantastic
again the extremely slow speech the
labored breathing the sniffing and not
making one iota of sense then in comes
Mike Pence who is remember he's running
this whole thing we'll follow up on that
component as well and says Travel is
being banned to Iran and watch Trump in
the background seeming like he's
struggling to stay awake the task force
met this morning and brought the
president a range of options and at his
direction we will be doing the following
first the president authorized action
today to add additional travel
restrictions on Iran we will be using
section 212 °f on banning travel from
Iran Iran is also already under a travel
ban but we are expanding existing travel
restrictions to include any foreign
national who has visited Iran within the
last fourteen days and then a key moment
Donald Trump asked about you've been
referring to all of this as a hoax now
someone has died do you stand by that
and Trump incomprehensibly says no what
I meant was that the hoax is on them on
the Democrats with kovat 19 what you
said the other day in the Cabinet Room
with African American leaders you've got
to get away from politics
you were down in Charleston last night
using the word hoax when talking about
Democrats somebody now is dead from this
do you regret that kind of talk no no
hoax referring to the action that they
take to try and pin this on somebody
because we've done such a good job the
hoax is on them not I'm not talking
about what's happening here I'm talking
what they're doing that's the hoax
that's just a continuation of the hoax
whether it's the impeachment hoax or the
Russia Russia Russia oh this is what I'm
talking about I challenge anyone to
explain what Trump means here when he
called it a hoax
he meant the hoax is on the Democrats
but it's also being perpetrated by the
Democrats that the Democrats are hoaxing
and being hoaxed but kovat 19 itself is
not the hoax imagine that and then
lastly here back to the topic of
Afghanistan Trump in this part gets
visibly confused he says we never should
have gone into Afghanistan under Obama
of course we went in before Barack Obama
Trump seems to realize it immediately
gets confused and says actually we
should have gone in it becomes a
complete and total mess you pride
yourself on a dealmaker but your former
national security visor john bolton he
said this is an Obama style deal and
sent the wrong message to Isis and al
Qaeda what did the Taliban give up here
you be hosting the Taliban in Washington
to Camp David or will you meet them
abroad look at that look nobody should
be criticizing this deal after 19 years
he had his chance he didn't do it he was
very much in favor of going in we should
have never gone in in the first place
when they went into when when they went
into Iraq listen listen when they went
into Iraq when they went into the Middle
East in such a fashion I was very much
against it shouldn't a gun gun and he
thought we should have that's been
proven wrong I'm surprised that anybody
would be against something where we try
and end a 19 year war were 8,000 miles
away from our home we've done a great
job in the sense that we've killed a lot
of terrorists we've put him out of
commission so then he actually says well
no I don't mean it was bad for Obama to
go into Afghanistan
I mean Bush shouldn't have gone into
Iraq I was against it that's a lied from
went on Howard
and said he was in favor but this is
actually all about Afghanistan anyway so
Obama's opinion or Trump's opinion about
Bush's Iraq war it has nothing to do
with what Donald Trump is doing in
Afghanistan it is nonsensical rambling I
got an email over the weekend from
someone who said David we see this guy
as an ignorant clown but a lot of his
followers see this same press conference
and they see strength and power and a
guy who's not going to be manipulated by
the libs and that's probably true that a
lot of Trumpets see this same press
conference that way and that's why we
can't convince them to vote for someone
other than Trump in November we simply
have to go around them this episode is
sponsored by blue Chu one of the things
I make a priority on the show is not to
perpetuate stigma for things that don't
deserve it we've talked about mental
health we've talked about many things
where we should all just be respectful
adults period and we would be better off
and blue two can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for blue to calm blue
like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda-approved
ingredient as in Viagra and Cialis it
can be taken day or night even on a full
stomach since it's chewable it works
twice as fast as a pill whenever the
opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue two prepares and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
comm get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's PA
que ma n pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the David Pakman show